beautiful afternoon in a sign of
pandemic progress
the united states is lowering mass
restrictions
starting today if you're fully
vaccinated
and you're outdoors you need and not in
a big crowd
you no longer need to wear a mask the
new guidance from the u.s centers for
disease control says that
even unvaccinated americans may now go
without masks outdoors
or while dining outside with friends but
that does not extend to
indoor events or crowded outdoor events
such as concerts
even when you're talking about variants
indoors outdoors
get vaccinated and you will certainly
have a degree of protection
but there are also troubling signs of
covid complacency
supersites in ohio texas and florida are
closing
louisiana is asking for fewer vaccine
shipments
counties in iowa and kansas are
rejecting them
and across the u.s a growing number of
americans have missed their second
vaccinations
call it vaccine hesitancy new data from
the cdc as of april
finds that eight percent of americans
have not taken their
second vaccine from pfizer or moderna
that's up from 3.4 percent earlier this
year
for me it would be a no thank you the
cdc now recommends that college students
be able to get their second dose
even if it's at home in another state
one dose
is partially effective after just one
dose
we know that you have reasonably good
protection 80 percent according to the
real world data
what we don't know however is is the
duration of that protection
that's why the second dose is crucial we
know after that second dose that those
antibodies last for at least six months
possibly longer the white house is
urging americans who are not getting the
one shot johnson and johnson vaccine to
take that double dose
the second dose is critical to getting
the maximum level of protection
not to mention that second dose is
critical in bringing the united states
to herd immunity
and that would stop the spread of the
virus john hendren al jazeera chicago